yeah it's crazy sport Holly Holm was
amazing she is because a as a person
mm-hmm I've never met her of it she's a
nice person ever she seems really sweet
and she just seems like I was listening
to her interviews you know it's just man
she seems just like a really up lifted
genuine person you know a super humble
you know she really is which is one of
the weirder moments why was such a weird
moment rather when Ronda Rousey at the
weigh-ins was like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
yourself you're [ __ ] fake and the
accent fit in and it was weird it was
like almost like she wanted her to be
the enemy did she get amped up to kick
her ass so sue sang a bunch of things
that didn't even make sense
maybe Rhonda was kind of at a breaking
point to just as far as like workload
stress level expectations you know
obligations and when I saw that weigh-in
actually I watched that probably at
least five times like I just replayed it
and because I like to watch people
interact and how they react I love it
yeah and I noticed like when I saw that
I'm like oh Holly's got this and I wish
I'd [ __ ] bet buddy wish I did but I
was watching that I was like oh just
thought because Rhonda seems so
emotional um it was the way Holly
reacted
that's why mmm she's just she's just
like Rhonda came in her space Holly just
like um stepped back like kept proper
distance you know like defensive
distance and super super low-key watch
her reaction yeah she stayed calm for
sure yeah that's that's skinny Rhonda -
that's weigh-in Rhonda yes depleted yeah
yeah she was kind of she was to put look
how much different when she was weighing
in but they tied up and Holly didn't
give any ground either she's just like
she stayed calm she she backed up but
like she backed up like I'm ready to hit
you backed up she didn't back up like uh
and then so Rhonda was super like eat
emotional - she was funny she was like I
was just trying to get a drink yeah I
just thought I was having a drink I
don't know yeah yeah that's great
and then Rhonda was like she was super
right I said you never saw her like that
you're like what the [ __ ] yeah yeah I
think you nailed it as far as the
breaking point
yeah she got sucked into all the
Hollywood [ __ ] they were putting her
in movies and TV shows and she was on
different talk shows - like songs could
she became Velasquez could she know it's
like oh my God look what she's doing to
these women could she remember that
right yeah there's like you know look I
was a positive yes I mean she is now
now she's a WWE Superstar it's just a
different kind of [ __ ]
you think she should yeah let me say
that I don't go out like that this is
Miriam talking no it's a different
person it's just she deserves better
than to go out the way you know her last
fight well she deserves she's actually
what she got she's no no this is what I
think she's better than that I think
you're right I think you're right she's
better than I think oh it's bad that she
got punched like that no no no no no I'm
saying she she just she deserves better
than that to like represent herself yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't think that
matters to her as much as it matters to
other folks I think she really cemented
her legacy as one of the greatest
women's MMA champions ever and a pioneer
but I also think that women's MMA has
evolved so fast that within the brief
time that she was running [ __ ] the sport
passed her by and when you see the one
that I was always worried about with her
was Amanda because I was like Amanda
Nunez has a black belt in Brazilian
jiu-jitsu and nasty hands like to meet
you know - right um I think she has some
judo I don't know what we're ranking
she's not belted in judo I don't know
she could be but I know she's a black
belt in jujitsu and I know she had heavy
hands
my thought was at Ronda although she was
developing good striking skills she's
known for judo in her arm bars that's
her big thing and the striking skills
were sort of like something that was
happening along the way and she was
starting to catch girls but she was
catching girls like betch Kouhei and you
know and Davis yeah but and and beating
them down when she gets him down they're
not nearly on the level of an Amanda
Nunez like you're not gonna catch her
like that
right exactly and my thought was that if
if it was gonna go down it was gonna be
Amanda because a man to just hit so
[ __ ] hard and then so when she came
back and immediately far for the world
title against Amanda she needed it gimme
[ __ ] yeah she needed well she needed a
different camp and I think that's fair
she needed a lot she needed a revamping
of her approach she need a lot of things
she need a lot of things because people
knew first of all she never shoots for
doubles she's not taking you down with
the lower body attack it's always upper
body and it's always a clinch and she
clinches with her left arm I mean Greg
Jackson and Jackson Winkeljohn they all
figured that out and then Holly had the
solution for that yeah yeah you know and
also there's other things when you can't
[ __ ] head kicked into oblivion that
way like you need a lot of time off a
lot of time with no sparring no nothing
especially just being so high like being
so untouchable and high mm-hmm and then
getting coming crashing down earth like
that so rough that's a definitely like a
big who am i moment I think I'm sure
yeah well there's a whole world too
right but you were talking about you
trying to figure out who you are when
you couldn't train anymore yeah and I
had that on such a like small scooter a
private private school and her
personally but private yeah yeah and
hers is the world yes and like in NY and
mine was like more tragic and hers was
more humility humiliating mmm you know
how was yours more tragic
it happened in third round of a fight
world taught if I MMA
it wasn't a clear like it happened on a
takedown it wasn't a takedown that
worked or tweaked my knee or grabbed on
my knee or
was I pushed against them while my body
was like this parallel to the ground and
I tore my own easy oh yeah so it's like
why is that more tragic because it was
more like no no no no no no no I think
it's more humiliating to get knocked out
in my opinion to get knocked out sure
than it is to get like injured out like
like tear tear outs like still fighting
and then you'd step back and you
everything slips and you fall right cuz
your knee can't it's gone yeah you know
that's what I mean when I say tragic Oh
or if you're like winning the winning
the fight and then unfortunate yeah yeah
yeah so it's more unfortunate and then
your identity stripped away but again
yours is private hers is public but at
least I understand what it's like to not
be that person who you you counted on
you being that person it's part of your
shield that you put on to go through the
day yeah for sure for sure
yeah you know yeah yeah her persona
she's damn good at it too
and then it's like stripped away